ty hilton not having to go elsewhere to
continue his career as he enters season
number 10 all of which with the
indianapolis colts back
on a one-year deal colts were looking at
sammy watkins you know a lot of times
this time of year
that's aimed at getting another guy who
has an offer on the table to jump on it
and there may have been a little
something going on there where when t.y
hilton heard that they were interested
in sammy watkins he decided i better
take what i can get and stay with the
colts i think he's still got plenty of
gas in the tank and now that they have
carson wentz hey
it's a guy who knows the city it's a guy
who knows the team it's a guy who knows
the coaching staff the
everything about it you know you're not
plugging in someone new that you don't
know and uh they found a way to keep him
and i think that's good for everybody
and they've got you know they've got
they've got some weapons offensively now
and if carson once can get back to the
guy who was pre-2020 this can be a very
competitive and dangerous team on both
sides of the ball
yeah mike right before we came on the
year i saw stephen holder i believe it
was from the indianapolis star reported
that one team offered ty hilton moore it
was not the chiefs he said but he didn't
name that team i will be curious to see
if that team is the ravens if it comes
out because this will be another
receiver who has passed up the ravens
which tells me something about receivers
wanting or not wanting to go to the
ravens uh we know they rank last in
passing offense last season they just
had trouble getting the ball down the
field so are they going to be able to
entice any receivers at all to come to
to baltimore that's going to be
interesting to see how that works out
but ty resigning with the colts just
seems like it was meant to be i would
like to see him finish his career there
i mean he's he's made a career of it he
did get more mike than i thought he
would get though 8 million guaranteed is
quite a bit of money for him who who did
not look like the same player over the
last two seasons that he has been early
in his career so we'll see what he can
do going forward if he can get his legs
back under him but it makes perfect
sense that he knows the offense and and
uh he'll be a key receiver for carson
wentz this season
are you telling me there's a mystery
team dun dun dun dun dun mystery team
yeah i'm always skeptical of the mystery
teams i want to know who who it was uh
and i want to know what they offered
otherwise you can anyone can say that
anyone can say that right i so
and i'm not saying that any one specific
reporter or source is lying but it's
kind of like the ped suspension where
they all say oh i took a supplement that
i didn't know was tainted they all say
it to the point where you can't believe
it when you hear it in any one specific
case especially when it's a mystery team
i'm just having some fun
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports